good day everyone
I need that one thank you thank you
man
it's a pleasure to be here thank you for
letting me stand on this audience and
bother you for a bit we've seen some
great talks this morning I was at the
rubenstock on uh on Greenhouse modeling
I loved his basic point of machine
learning is just our coping mechanism
for the fact that we don't know the
castle mechanisms
sad song
I also loved Mauricio's talk just now
where she reinforced Mark's points
that facts do not speak for themselves
all data is subjective and biased and
it's the way that we represent it
that determines how it's interpreted and
that's actually a big part of our job
too now I'm Marine managing data
scientist at capgemini
and I'm actually slightly very much
intimidated by you all
because I'm not an engineer
I'm a social scientist statistician
sociology criminology and years and
years ago my dad asked me well what the
heck are you going to do for a living
same as many of your parents might have
asked years ago
I was studying Utrecht Utrecht
University represent yay which is the
most quantitative social science faculty
in the country so while my dad was
wondering is he going to talk about
people's feelings yes Dad I studied
Freud I was actually modeling
pandemics
this is my work on Ebola 2014-15 my
internship at gyro 555 I was doing
stupid Excel stuff back then modeling
the the money spent on the islands in
the Philippines After the haian flood
and then suddenly Ebola happened the
world's biggest pandemic back then
remember
yeah I know I know
um so we started getting data from West
Africa what's the situation at how it's
spreading and I was suddenly using
models I learned during uh geo geography
about spatial distributions how it moves
across regions in sbss and r
yes I like R and I'm not afraid of
admitting it
um
to model
Howard was spreading across West Africa
that's actually a visualization I made
it was used on the Dutch national news
so I took a picture of the television
sent it to my mom saying here look show
Dad I'm do actually doing stuff because
I learned at that point in time that the
[ __ ] we do with data can help save lives
because we raised 10.6 million euros
back then to send emergency aid to West
Africa and I realized that's man that's
all I want to do in life
and that's what the rest of this talk is
going to be about basically
so I I graduated not on electoral
outcome uh models that was another one
but on crime prediction Rotterdam anyone
Rotterdam
hey good so I live on the upper upper
left over there I made this for the
police and for Abu Talib spatial
distribution of crime and what
neighborhood level factors do and do not
affect it over the years
basically how many people get stabbed
where and why
and what you can potentially do about it
but this was 2016 so then I had a
interview at capgemini and they said wow
that's cool that's data science that's
AI
and I said uh-huh
because I needed a damn job and that's
how he became a data scientist any
questions
because back then it wasn't even data
signs it was all big data more on that
later but from there I progressed to
modeling the yield for farmers in knei
and India some sometimes I talk about it
on stages and sometimes we test facial
recognition algorithms to see whether
you should paint yourself as a tiger or
as David Bowie or as Braveheart
the to dodge facial recognition
algorithms big hint is actually Tigers
so if you plan to you know do a hit
paint your face as a tiger because the
horizontal stripes make make
um image recognition models mistake
those stripes for eyebrows and ever
since covet most facial recognition
models are over
um are overfitting on eyebrows and eyes
Okay more more on that later um hands up
whoever worked with big data
who is from the area era when everything
was Big Data
you old bastards to dinosaurs but let's
be honest the Big Data memes were pretty
good back then we had dinosaur memes
about big data about how big data was
going to solve every damn problem in the
in the field because if dinosaurs had
big data
they would have seen the meteorite
coming and they could have you know
migrated or some [ __ ]
um and they uh yeah they basically had
dinosaurs had big data they would have
firm found a solution for a sustainable
um life post impact
the joke here is obviously that big data
was not the answer to the problem but
back then big data and Hadoop was the
solution to every problem who here knows
Hadoop
who here still uses Hadoop
my point exactly
because we've had a lot of buzzwords
since and as managing data scientists it
is part of my job to explain why no this
is a terrible idea
because the first on the list back then
Buzz was Big Data basically anything too
large to store on a single computer but
what was Big Data 10 years ago is now
just damn data because I have four
terabytes in my closet in my hallway
we used to need to require an entire
cluster for it now I can run it on my
laptop big data is dead long live big
data we had internet of things as in
hype everything had to be connected or
as Dutch like to say Internet of Things
as one word no space is allowed try it
um because oh yeah it's great it's going
to solve everything machine learning is
going to solve everything no it's just a
coping mechanism because we don't know
the causal effects as a statistician in
me
um suddenly everything cloud is going to
fix uh everything or gpus and deep
learning is going to sell solve
everything
let's remember for a moment that 2013
nvidia's Atlas GPU Unleashed neural Nets
and deep learning upon the world and we
have that entire field thanks to video
games
because without video games Nvidia
wouldn't have developed that GPU I often
remind my dad of this
an artificial intelligence thing and I
remember being told Mariah you're an AI
expert go talk to them why you build
machine learning right yeah I built two
models and one works good then you're an
expert go
that room was slightly smaller than this
one I was nervous
and we had the whole low code thing
because everyone once started hiring
data science teams who didn't produce
[ __ ] because it was 10 econometricians
in one corner with data and you expect
magic to happen
obviously mismanaged because you didn't
need Engineers you need visualization
you need proper storytelling all that
so those teams failed and then all the
organizations said we hate data
scientists we want low quote platforms
so we can just clicky and don't need
them and all those low code platforms
some of which are great started selling
yeah you don't need data scientists if
you just buy my damn tool of course that
also failed but that was another hype
that was two three years ago but some
are still stuck there blockchain is the
biggest hype if all if you ask me
because it's just a way to distribute
your data without a central Authority
so I don't get why financial
institutions Central authorities are so
interested in a system meant to
invalidate them but that's not me and
now we have [ __ ] metaverse dudes what
do we do with that they keep asking me
these questions yeah can we do something
with metaverse and I'm like here I have
this VR demo from five years ago it's
like oh wow that's metaphors
Pro tip anything VR these days is now
meta whatever but this brings me to the
core point that it's really all data it
was so 10 years ago and it will still be
10 year in the future I just don't know
what
those words still be bothering us with
at that point in time
I hope it's not Quantum I swear to God
um
but our job is pretty secure because 10
years ago they didn't know how to use a
fax machine or a copy machine and they
still don't
and entire Generations have to die
before the average person in society
knows how computer works so we're good
we're good
to my core point because this is the
cover of Euro a Neuromancer anyone know
the book technocentrism the belief that
technology has all the answers and will
solve everything and selective
technocentrism that is our current day
and era whenever I'll open my LinkedIn
feed this new tech thing will solve our
problems just like big data would save
the dinosaurs 10 years ago and I'm
disappointed because I like dinosaurs
but they're no longer here so big data
failed
now I can talk a little bit about the
projects I and we some of my colleagues
over there actually do
as data scientists I can talk about how
uh how we predict burnouts based on HR
data and what goes wrong a lot I can
talk about outlier detection how how we
check use fraud systems to see who
drives lease cars
to Disneyland and says it's for business
more than you think more than you think
actually there was also cases of people
driving around at night 11 at night
from home to a non-work related location
and then back home at three
which was probably our system picking up
booty calls
or considering their age cheating
which is not okay but I guess it's okay
but not if you say it's for business can
then you can get screwed in another way
detection algorithms or Refugee crisis I
though the work on the upper right is my
work for the Dutch government from years
ago on flows of refugees in out and out
of the country
uh it was a Time series model who worked
great the the purple line was my
prediction the pink line was the
standard that was just the XL based
average of the last year that was their
prediction before I came in and the red
line is what really happened and you can
see the start of covet that's when all
the models went to [ __ ] because all the
board was closed and I only had yeah I
only have data on the past not of the
future
tough life tough life
um could talk about
um what we're doing for Farmers I
mentioned those earlier I'm flying to
India next uh next week to model this
did you know that half the food in the
world is produced by smallholder farmers
not super Farms with tractors and drones
that's all a really cool drone here by
the way
um but smallholder Farms with two three
hectares of land and a donkey
and we built a platform a data platform
it's called project Farm because
my company likes to talk about AI
whatever but we can't show what we've
done because we get an NDA on our heads
if we do
so we built this stuff pro bono for
farmers in India Maharashtra West Bengal
and in Kenya
to help predict their yields assess how
much fertilizer they need to use how
much seeds they need and a lot of that
is very simple optimization but those
very simple models stuffed into an app
help those Farmers a great deal and from
that I learned that it's not about the
most sophisticated or coolest deep
learning model it's about building a
model that works and solves solves
problems for people
we're doing the same for the world food
program actually
we have like five to ten percent of the
world that does not meet nutritious
needs does not have access to the bare
minimum for food but almost 40 percent
of the world does not have a healthy
diet or cannot does not have the
financial means to access a healthy diet
now the world food program for decades
has run complex models on how to figure
out how to optimize based on their
pricing constraints nutrition
constraints constraints and
environmental constraints the cheapest
way to feed as many people as possible
in case say grain prices suddenly Spike
like happened this summer they calculate
what is the cheapest way to import food
to feed more people as nutritiously as
possible if they do that calculation
better and faster less people dead
which is a very scary thing but also a
very important thing the main challenge
they're running it in Excel and it takes
them like a week
and we're helping them do it in minutes
or hours and those two [ __ ]
right over there are helping me build it
so give it up to the max over there
thank you Max
[Applause]
um and we were delivering the second MVP
this uh this uh this December the first
one went online this summer
and the primary feedback at that point
in time was that the dashboards weren't
live yet
so the output of the entire model now in
a minute will still Excel and I was
deeply ashamed
deeply ashamed because I wanted to be
fancy I wanted to be cool and Slick I'm
a consultant
and then Claudia told me Marine it used
to take us a week now it's going to take
us minutes I don't give a damn that it's
still in Excel
which was my reality check
dudes and dudettes it's about the impact
you make not how fancy it looks
and lastly we have great examples of AI
being used by my friends nowadays to
produce excellent poor I mean art art
yeah fan art yes
I mean it's crazy technology these days
you know
to give one slight example of the
burnout model I just mentioned where we
use standard HR data so when did
somebody join pay raises uh promotions
um responsibilities to predict who is
going to drop either by leaving the
company or because they have a burnout
and the data privacy officer was already
loading the shotgun and pointing it at
me of course because I was coming in
saying I want there to know their gender
their ethnicity and if you have it their
sexual orientation
why do you need that well otherwise I
can't tell if my model is discriminating
because privacy and transparency are
mutually exclusive in this world and of
course I was just running linear
regression here because my goal was not
to predict who was going to drop but why
because if I'm just saying who's going
to drop and HR has the conversation oh
your computer says you're going to get a
burnout what do you think is going to
happen
and I am profiling so gdpr will Lynch me
but if I use lime models some of you
might recognize this use LINE models to
explain for each individual in my data
set at what point and for what reasons
they score high or low like John over
here fake data who scores is on in the
green about overtime which is the most
common reason for a burnouts if you look
at literature but what is an
environmental satisfaction is job level
put him at risk so you'd have should
have a talk about that and don't talk
about overtime now I was um at the world
summer day I about two months ago in a
panel with five experts on the great
resignation who knows what the great
resignation is
good which is a bit okay for for the
youngsters less so but the labor markets
is right like really good A lot of
people are wrestling a lot of people are
changing jobs and that entire panel was
talking about yeah we need to think
about the digital citizen of the future
and we need to
um let them work from home and let them
work abroad and I need more pizza
parties and they need to have a foosball
table
because that's how you retain people
well I don't know about you but in
pretty much every data science project I
start Google Scholar is the first thing
I hit up to see if people smarter than
me already figured this out
so for this talk I hit up Google Scholar
again and figured out the free three
biggest predictors for people leaving
our age marriage and time in service
well you're not going to influence those
right
unless you give people a bonus for
getting married I guess
I'm not ready for that by the way
um but the three biggest predictors that
you do have influence on so their level
in the organization they're they're
training their their pay and who's the
manager
you can all influence but you made kpis
saying you can't
so young Marine years ago was presenting
this model to a large organization who
had a huge burnout and nutrition problem
and I was explaining well in your
particular case it's actually four
managers who are causing the majority of
burnouts
of course those four were in the room
what do you think happened next
yeah I got I got yelled at my motto was
bad evil and probably racist and I got
yeah that the whole project went to shed
basically I learned a lot there about
shooting the messenger about how to tell
your story
how not to tell your story I think two
of the managers got the boot in the end
but my entire Point here is that these
are Big predictors of the issue
according to signs and according to our
data data science
and pizza parties and football tape ping
pong tables really are not big
predictors but the only reason
management talks about those is because
they're not allowed to change the rest
and if management can't solve a problem
in the short term they don't talk about
it
that's a social scientist again because
this was my biggest shock when I entered
the field I don't know about you after
uh after graduating that in science
you're judged for your methods my
professor would terrorize me with you
didn't think of this you didn't
standardize that whereas in business
you're judged based on your outcomes
which is like the polar opposite and
nobody prepared me for it did they
prepare prepare you for that
no way I see a lot of heads going like
that okay me too me too it's okay bro
um so instead you get feedback like this
yeah but is it scalable yeah but this is
accurate but is it biased no model is
unbiased
and no human is unbiased that's why we
need both data and people to control
each other but the people that ask these
questions the most usually have the most
to hide because they're just coming up
with excuses because they don't want
more compliancy and they don't want
people to have a second opinion a
database data driven opinion
so data science is just using methods
from science to solve data problem I'm
sorry Mark I very much loved your talk
but I disagree data science is totally
science especially when I'm sitting
across a business manager who only talks
about yeah but this is going to
influence my kpi I still feel like a
scientist at that point in time
and I'm not sure if Sun Tzu said this
come to think of it but he should have
and this brings me to a very personal
issue about data and Truth
who here recognose of mh17
okay that's all the dutchies at least
um
this was the time Marine crashed Twitter
back in 2014 in the Big Data era
remember Big Data yeah a lot of hands
big data
um when we were Geo tracking that stuff
because I was already in the scene back
then and then the whole plane just
disappeared it got shot down over
Ukraine
years later we figured out it was a buck
missile shot by Russian insurgents who
did it but at that point we didn't know
amaran had data leaked data recordings
in Russian of people talking about yeah
we shot down an airplane but the exif
data data generated at the points of
generation of the file showed that the
audio file was produced the day
before the airplane got shot down on the
16th
meaning was the whole thing is set up
at that point in time based on the data
we had at that point in time because we
didn't standardize for time differences
along amongst other things
we thought we had evidence that the
whole thing was fake so I posted that on
Twitter and went absolutely viral
it's still up there damn
that's when I quit Twitter admittingly
Twitter is now more fun than ever but
you got what I mean
that was the data we had at the time
that's what we what we believed at the
time that's where we based our actions
on and we should never judge people I
think for acting based on the data they
have but we should judge them for for
not trying to get better data
so I have friends in Ukraine and this
[ __ ] is still happening even today this
was on the news this year at the NOS
Dutch national news explaining about how
many people in Ukraine identify as
Russian except the data they're
displaying here has nothing to do with
identifying the data was who speaks
Russian
and just like speaking and identifying
is not the same as what you have over
here and what you identify as
if we follow this style of reason the
Netherlands should totally Annex Belgium
because half of the [ __ ] speaks
Dutch
but actually why shouldn't we they've
only been independent for 200 years
right any any belgiums in the room
okay let's go
um
so my point here is this is dangerous
stuff and this is in part just because
there's no proper fact checking or
misinterpretation known or unknown but
it's happening at scale and it's
happening today and it has a very real
impact in how people view very big
things happening nowadays
plus the Dutch national news which is
just isn't isn't the best you know I
I have friends in Kiev I have friends
fighting on the front line right now and
based on their reports it's not about
identification either this is about the
weight of evidence
and just now we had a great talk about
that somebody uh talked about
with great explorative uh power comes
great explanative responsibility
and I like that
um otherwise we're stuck in a hyper
reality as described by boatrier all
those years ago and everyone's seen The
Matrix where you have multiple
points of data data points multiple
views that don't exist that mute that
are mutually exclusive but you can't
prove or disprove either so you're
living in multiple realities at the same
time
which when I talk to any 13 year old is
pretty much the world we're living in
today
and a lot of us call it fake news I
prefer to call it propaganda because I
studied that stuff and it's nothing news
we've been doing that for over well over
a hundred years
um but it is the big part of my field of
our field that I fell in love with NLP
image recognition social media analytics
that we don't even talk about that much
and some none of the speakers about that
slightly disappointed but not in this
disappointing speakers on their own
because
I'm actually loving the stories
um Mark already mentioned this
Yandex anyone know yeah what Yandex uh
and Moscow and taxis happened
yeah that he talked about this morning
Yandex which is Russia's Google got got
hacked they do the the Uber Services
over there so
um anonymous because this was Anonymous
back in Action started asking all the
taxis in Moscow to come to Hotel Ukraine
the entire city was messed up for the
entire day because it was taxis
everywhere
Hotel Ukraine by the way was founded by
Stalin himself so it sounds like we're
living in in real life cyberpunk
and actually I do believe the future is
now we're living in a real a real life
cyberpunk world it's just a lot of a lot
less goggles and outfits and a whole lot
more scary subversive stuff
now
I don't have to explain to you to you
guys what's happening in the Eastern
side of our country but I am going to
ask of you who here has ever been uh on
Tinder
professionally
okay okay
so
um
I got the message from a friend saying
hey Moran in February I'm going to talk
to you less I'm going to be offline more
how so I'm moving to the front line I'm
like the front line
are you Ukrainian he's like yeah I just
called him Eastern European bastard he
called me Western European Ambassador
this is how he bonded they became
friends online so turns out I knew
people fighting on the front lines I'm
like I'm I'm [ __ ] with an ak's 47 what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do
so I went on Tinder
used to GPS spoof to pretend to be on
the Russia Ukraine Borough border
grab some Instagram pictures
and pretended to be a hot blonde
ah I mean I can pull that off right
right right I started using the My Old
Dungeons and Dragons names nobody knew
nobody had to know
and you start matching with people
soldiers on that Russia Ukraine border
because they handed in their phone when
they crossed the border but when they're
still stuck over there in the cold
either bothering each other or bothering
women
you match with Ivan or whatever and
Tinder tells you you're 10 km kilometers
away from the [ __ ]
okay and then you start sending you
certain pictures that I shan't describe
here any further
ladies suddenly I understand how
terrible it is to date online
I get to you now I'm so sorry I would
like to apologize on behalf of all men
but the thing is I was doing this with
50 other Bros
I think I assume they're all bros
um and he also matches with Ivan but is
20 kilometers away
this
is a dick dick
it is the world's smallest antelope
it resides in South Africa and like 13
year olds it marks its territory with
its tears
I know I know it's adorable so because I
don't want to say pick out here because
it's being recorded I'm gonna say dick
dick pic okay okay so we have the
Russian Ukrainian border over here and
we are gathering data and I know I I get
a dick dick pic
damn
um but another guy receives the same
dick dick pic so we so we bet you know
and we know where it's roughly coming
from Nick Nick is over here okay great
and we got another one from over here
another dig deck pick great but if you
do this for a few nights
you suddenly know where the distribution
of dig deck takes lies
mainly in Belarus
meaning you have Intel on where the
Russian reinforcements are hiding across
the Russia Ukraine border which is very
real Intel for a modern conflict
achieved
and gained
through methods that scarred me for life
and then somebody asked me Moraine isn't
this privacy shouldn't you worry about
you know uh gdpr I'm like well first of
all this is not Europe yet secondly
they're most likely dead so who cares
um
um yeah so
you can actually Google this and you can
try Pinder for yourself which is my new
favorite
python
library because goddamn it allows you to
connect to Tinder through API
um you can look me up on L magazine
because they published an article about
it because they wanted to talk about the
brave women helping out online
I'll take that as a compliment at this
point
because a joke ladies and gentlemen is
that the world didn't change that much
back in 2008 I was stuck in Wikileaks we
were using we were using text analytics
very basic text analytics to figure out
which part of you of uh Afghanistan was
being shot up because America said we're
fighting over here we're using leaked
documents and basic NLP to show no
you're also fighting over there to speak
truth to power to show through data
what's happening and where the war
crimes are at
and where Reuters journalists are being
shot
and thus stuff is still happening today
except now it's in HD
we're still Gathering data through open
sources through social media we're
looking at either these are stress
strapped strapped for parts migs or
they're actually fake migs we're not
sure but we're using satellite imagery
and automatic image recognition to
analyze it we get to see people looting
this video Gamers who are no stalker the
game
lead AI developer for stalker 2 the
sequel in Kiev I know people in the
studio
you know what he told me I'm Ryan I'm
going to talk to you less I'm going to
do get some inspiration
on the front line now he's fighting I
haven't heard from him two and [ __ ]
months
I hope he's still alive
this is the mechanisms chain don't
change only the ways in which they
manifest themselves we still have data
we still have a ton of problems
worldwide and we can still use data to
help
people
and new technology is never the problem
in that Legacy is I'm pretty pretty sure
sons who that said this I want to
believe Sun Tzu said this
and the fake was always real fake news
is nothing new propaganda is nothing new
we will always have data that is biased
and misinformed and try is trying to
influence uh influence you and makes you
think certain things and that doesn't
mean it's bad this just means we need
more data to battle it
rather than less just like you think
this is the final slide but this isn't
even my final slide
I posted about this this is Russian
national news it's great I mean it's an
American swastika with the Ukraine flag
and the feminism symbol and pretty much
every religion and socialism there which
is pretty much everything evil and I
posted about it and my post got Shadow
banned basically nobody gets to see it I
after half an hour I only had 18 views
until I removed the words swastika and
Islam from it and then it started
trending meaning pretty much database
evidence that linkedin's algorithm is
basically a control F of bad words and
then they block your [ __ ] good luck
being in an Islam Professor here we're
using data to address real bias
not in oh but what if AI evil but social
media censorship which is the most
realistic issue in AI bias I can give
you right now and we're not talking
about it nearly as much as I would like
to please do like and subscribe
we can only we can never be right I
don't believe we can ever be right but
we can be slightly less wrong
and that's what we do as data scientists
thank you
[Applause]
now questions
so
we have one there
please don't tell me this was a coherent
story
no it wasn't and it's very hard to
follow up on such a presentation so I'm
just gonna ask a dry question and maybe
that'll make it easier for other people
to think of one so models you use models
to make decisions what's in your opinion
the limit of models where do you stop
believing them and how do you make
decisions then
I've
um I'm going to use the forecasting for
for migrants as an example where we I
was using a ton of mixed models I was
using actually boost model around forest
model uh some deep learning methods even
a linear regression model and I was
making the trade-off in the end between
one explainability and accuracy on the
other hand and that's when I first
learned that it is not our job to build
a model sorry it's not your job to build
a model
it's your job to pick the right model
and the right methods and that's why
it's called data science and in this
case the cutoff there was barely an
increase or gain in Performance Based
based on methods so I went with the
simplest model possible so I could
explain to government employees what the
heck was happening and what they needed
to do because if they don't understand
your model they don't believe your model
they're not going to act on it then
you're just talking to a wall
so we I think it was an Einstein quote
but I'm not sure
always use the simplest explanation
possible but no more simple than that
thanks thank you do we have any other
questions
don't be shy he's here
for us sir otherwise I can ask you a
question
um you you talked about propaganda you
showed some of the projects and the last
one you had was let's say art
um but there's also for it I mean you
you showed the fun side of that but
there's also a dark side with these
models
um like deep fakes and picture
generation that at some point very soon
we're getting
to an age where you you don't know if
something's real that you see
um is there anything that we can do
about it is that just an inevitability
that we're just gonna not believe the
news anymore at one end I believe we
need to have better regulation better
constraints about this better better
fact checking also from
um from uh from a journalism side of
view on the other side I think it's an
immaturity thing for us as a society
when did you all learn how to type when
you were 18 20 when you 12
more elect 12. thank you
um Generations before I was learned to
type when there were 30 or 40 or they
said oh I don't need to learn to type or
use a computer my work is way too
valuable for that those bastards have
all been automated Away by now my point
here is that learning to use a computer
learning to type and even using math and
statistics I dreaded learning statistics
and that's why I mentioned math and
people go like on average but applying
it is fun and not as hard as learning it
and we as a society have to become more
mature in using data and taking stuff
online as objective truth but that takes
decades in the same way I'm going to use
a terrible example one of my favorite
German writers pointed out that after
World War II
Germany didn't think oh we've been to
bad guys all along no they thought they
were they felt as a society that they
were the victim sorry I'm sociologist
here I go they thought they had been
bombed and defeated and everything was
terrible they felt they were the victims
and it took them 20 years
for the societal
um
the the societal point of view to shift
into oh yeah we were the baddies why
because two generations had to die
which brings me back to this issue part
of it is temporary because new
technology is never the problem Legacy
is thank you
foreign
[Applause]